[Musique]
bonjour Dany Peter bonjour Patrice
Carouge vous êtes le secrétaire de la
situation vide Maurepas et je vous ai
demandé de venir parce qu'il va y avoir
une formidable exposition à Maurepas à
partir du 18 avril et on verra que 18
avril c'est pas un hasard
qui est consacré au ghetto de Varsovie
c'est au café de la plage à Maurepas
c'est ça tout à fait exact donc cette
exposition a été réalisée par le
Mémorial de la Shoah qui est donc
l'organisme qui comprend le plus
d'historiens qualifiés pour narrer cette
période tragique de l'histoire et donc
c'est une exposition itinérante qui est
actuellement également
montré à Lausanne en Suisse sous le
patronage de Robert Badinter très bien
voilà donc c'est une exposition qui
tourne un peu dans le en Europe ou dans
le il y a plusieurs il y a plusieurs
exemplaires de cette exposition bien sûr
et donc c'est une exposition qui a été
monter à l'occasion ou le souligner il y
a quelques instants du 80ème
anniversaire du soulèvement du vaisseau
qui est arrivé le 19 avril 1943 et de
façon on va reparler dans quelques
instants un mot quand même sur
l'exposition parce que alors évidemment
elle est un peu secrète jusqu'à ce que
son ouverture mais qu'est-ce qu'on y
voit c'est quoi c'est surtout des photos
c'est alors
c'est un mélange de textes et de
documents
texte réalisé et écrit par les
historiens du Mémorial de la Shoah avec
des documents qui montrent des photos du
ghetto des photos de la révolte du
ghetto et des photos de ce qu'on appelle
les archives ringle Bloom c'est à dire
des archives secrètes du ghetto qui ont
été découvertes après la guerre parce
que l'historien Emmanuel blonde avait
pris conscience que le témoignage
des gens du ghetto risquaient de
disparaître et le ghetto qui a été
complètement brûlé
liquidée de rester que des ruines on a
retrouvé par miracle les caisses
d'archives grâce
si j'ose dire au fait que deux des
membres de cette organisation qui avait
organisé ringle Bloom qui s'appelait
onec Chabbat ça veut dire le plaisir du
shabbat c'est traditionnellement à la
sortie du shabbat de samedi soir et les
Juifs se réunissaient se réunissent pour
fêter
shabbat et faire une cérémonie de
séparation entre le shabbat qui est le
jour saint et la semaine qui est la
période non non consacrée et donc ils
avaient choisi ce nom pour ne pas
attirer l'attention des mouchards qui
existaient dans dans le ghetto en disant
on va on va au next shabbat c'est-à-dire
que on va fêter
shabbatiques mais en réalité c'était de
l'organisation dans laquelle il y avait
évidemment un certain nombre
d'historiens un certain nombre de
personnes et ont survécu
hirschwasser et Madame overbart qui ont
après-guerre dit indiquer où était le où
étaient les documents mais le ghetto
ayant été complètement rasé par les SS
il fallait reconstituer le cadastre et
le croisement des rues et donc on a
fouillé pendant huit mois pour retrouver
la première caisse il y avait trois
endroits la première caisse a été
retrouvée au bout de 8 mois la seconde
au bout de quatre ans
et la dernière n'a jamais été retrouvé
donc le troisième moyen donc
on sait pas les chercheurs hésitent
dans le jardin de l'ambassade de Chine
mais il y a eu des fouilles très
récemment je crois dans les années 80 et
elles n'ont pas outils donc ces archives
Engel Bloom donc il y a formidable parce
que c'est des témoignages
sont parce que les témoignages sur cette
période sont essentiellement allemands
très peu de survivants il y a des
survivants mais je dirais que les
témoignages photographiques ou les
témoignages visuels sont sont allemands
pour les
photos qu'on verra pendant d'autres
conversations sur des photos d'origine
SS enfin d'origine il y a fait
d'ailleurs pour montrer aux autorités
himler enfin combien ils étaient voilà
ils tuaient des gens enfin ils mettaient
ou pas
notre boulot c'était de liquider le
ghetto et jurgenstrop lors de son fameux
télégramme il n'y a plus de ghetto juifs
à varso modo
qui a commandité qui a commandité la la
fin je dirais l'extermination et la
liquidation du ghetto je dis
extermination parce que il a sur la fin
utiliser tous les moyens qui lui
paraissaient nécessaire pour réduire à
néant et anéantir vraiment au sens
premier tous les Juifs qui qui
demeuraient sur les 500000 Juifs
peut-être qu'on fera peut-être un petit
rétrospective historique mais il y avait
il y a eu un moment 500 000 Juifs dans
le ghetto une partie une très grande
partie a été exterminée à séminaire à
très binka et puis il restait 60000
personnes et donc entre nous 43 avril
il reste 60000 personnes 35000 10%
35000 qui sont entre guillemets recensés
et 25000 qu'on appelait les sauvages
parce qu'ils étaient cachés depuis des
mois dans les caves dans les
dans les souterrains va pars partout il
était possible de se cacher voilà donc
on va peut-être revenir un petit peu en
arrière c'est-à-dire
ce ghetto de Varsovie il y en invasion
de la Pologne par l'Allemagne entre 9 le
ghetto de Varsovie il existe déjà alors
dans dans les dans les villes polonaises
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est bon il y a 3
millions de à peu près de Juifs en
Pologne
il y avait à l'époque en Allemagne dans
l'Allemagne de Hitler il y avait à peu
près 300 400000 Juifs qui étaient des
Juifs
donc c'est une proportion très
importante il y a une différence
fondamentale entre les Juifs allemands
et les juifs polonais les Juifs
allemands sont des Juifs qui sont pour
la plupart complètement assimilés dans
la société donc depuis de nombreuses
années en particulier depuis moisis
mondelson donc qui était un contemporain
de Kant donc à la fin du 18e siècle les
Juifs allemands sont devenus des Juifs
de confession des Allemands de
confession israélite alors que les
Polonais étaient restés enfin les juifs
polonais étaient restés juifs polonais
donc ils étaient ils étaient
à Paris
totalement dans la société il y avait
deux types de population la population
rurale qui vivait dans ce qu'on appelle
les
petites bourgades juives bon je vais pas
raconter l'histoire mais il y a eu la
Pologne était sous emprise soviétique
russe
sous emprise allemande et sous emprise
autrichienne de 1795 et 1918 donc elle
n'existait pas en tant qu’était
indépendant et donc peu importe mais les
juifs polonais vivaient donc dans les
dans les bourgades
et dans les villes et dans les villes il
y avait beaucoup de villes où la
population juive était une des
populations les plus importantes il y
avait même des villes où les Juifs
étaient majoritaires donc si on regarde
Varsovie Varsovie la population juive
est de 300 à peu près 350 000 âmes au
1er septembre 39 et on se retrouve
donc avec une population de 30%
juive à Varsovie donc pour répondre à
votre question il y avait donc des
quartiers des quartiers des quartiers
donc si vous regardez un peu les
l'évolution de l'habitat
par exemple au Canada on avait fait une
étude très intéressante il y avait un
quartier qui était grec puis les Grecs
ont déménagé le quartier a été remplacé
par des Polonais et puis après les
Polonais ont déménagé le même quartier
et devenu un quartier russe etc donc les
gens migraient par par
ils savent voilà par affinité ils se
regroupés par affinité donc il y avait
donc il y avait non pas un ghetto il y
avait des quartiers il y avait un
quartier un quartier important dont la
majorité était juive mais il y avait il
y avait des Juifs c'était 30% de la
population
une partie donc à l'ouest de la Vistule
qui était majoritairement juive et puis
du quartier qui était magiquement non
juifs mais avec une minorité juive qui
était qui était qui était quand même
existante donc
il y avait pas de ghetto il y avait des
il y avait donc dans cette zone de
d'habitat plus juive des commerces des
industries des juives alors le ghetto et
quand les conditions
sont arrivés le premier ils sont arrivés
le 1er octobre
9 quand 39 à Varsovie donc en ayant
envahi la Pologne un mois auparavant et
donc la Pologne la capitale de la
Pologne
n'est plus et les Allemands décident de
gérer la population juive à leur manière
donc il y a un partage
de la Pologne 3 une première partie qui
est complètement à l'ouest la Pologne
qui est rattaché
à l'Allemagne cette jeune Grand Reich la
partie centrale qui est le gouvernorat
général et donc il va être dirigé par un
certain Hans Franck et puis la partie
Est qui va devenir soviétique suite aux
accords
entre les accords signés entre salines
et Hitler entre donc Molotov et ventrop
et donc ce pack Germano soviétique
donc va sceller le destin de la partie
est bon à Varsovie les Allemands
décident de regrouper immédiatement les
Juifs dans la partie la plus peuplée de
Juifs de Varsovie et ça démarre tout de
suite c'est à dire que les 39 des 39
donc
il commence à faire des des
opérations pour
[Musique]
intimider les Juifs etc et les inciter à
vivre
et ça veut dire cette opération voilà
cette opération va durer
de méfiance va durer à peu près une
année ils vont se servir d'un prétexte
au départ qui est le typhus c'est-à-dire
que il y a eu en Pologne avant
l'invasion allemande il y a eu des
épidémies typhuses donc là il y a une
épidémie diffuse et ils vont et
d'ailleurs il y a un panneau à
l'exposition que l'on montre qui qui
raconte effectivement attention zone de
typhus ne pas ne pas pénétrer et donc
dans cette zone ils vont dire que la
vermine juive diffuse le typhus ça
rappelle la peste transportée au
Moyen-Âge par les Juifs etc donc
c'est de dire aux gens laissez-les entre
eux ne venez pas et donc ne sortez pas
et
qui diffuse le typhus c'est pas c'est
pas bien qui se répand dans la vie et
donc il faut au contraire les regrouper
et donc dès le 12 octobre 1940 le ghetto
est constitué et il est fermé d'accord
il est fermé par un mur donc je pense
que vous avez des photos de ce mur ce
mur qui va qui va être au frais de va
être construit au frais de la communauté
obligatoire il fait 18 km de long il
relie les rues avec quelques fois un
côté qui est du côté à rien et de
l'autre côté qui est du côté juif donc
le numéro de séparation et ce mur va
avoir au début une vingtaine de
d'ouverture de portes qui vont être
gardés d'un côté parce qu'on appelle la
police juive et de l'autre côté par les
Allemands et les Polonais donc la police
polonaise et la police enfin les
Allemands et donc ce ce nom de ghetto
comme comme vous le savez vient de
puisque le premier ghetto a été
constitué à Venise et donc c'était les
endroits où il y avait des Forges qui
plutôt les bijoux c'est le mot ghetto
qui vient de la forge en italien voilà
et donc il y a beaucoup de partisans
juifs qui forgent et voilà je
pourrais pas je ne sais pas et donc il
se trouve donc que le ghetto est
construit il fermait les Juifs ne
peuvent plus sortir il y a des maladies
comme je viens de l'expliquer et les
Allemands décident de gérer un petit peu
le ghetto par l'intermédiaire de ce
qu'on appelle le yoga c'est-à-dire le
Conseil le Conseil juif qui est en fait
parce que parfois on a on a accusé aussi
des organisations juste d'avoir un peu
laissé faire les choses c'est très
intéressant de s'arrêter un peu
là-dessus pour si vous voulez pour
l'expliquer alors le Yoda
c'est dans chaque ville où il y avait
des ghettos puisque Varsovie n'était pas
unique bien sûr
puisque la position du gouverneur à une
gouverneur de de Pologne était de
regrouper de vider les stettles que tu
es les petites bourgades et de regrouper
dans les grandes villes pour pouvoir
mieux mieux les surveiller et mieux les
exterminer par la suite et donc on se
trouve dans ce contexte avec
des responsables juifs qui vont faire
l'interface on emploie cette expression
moderne entre la population la
population juive et les autorités
alimentent il faut quand même imaginer
que les Allemands n'ont ne veulent pas
gérer ce qui se passe à l'intérieur du
ghetto d'accord de façon
totale donc il délègue au lieu d'un rat
un certain nombre de tâches par exemple
la poste il y a pas de poste les
Allemands ils connaissent
pas la Poste qui est aux mains donc de
des Allemands n'existe plus donc et les
gens du ghetto ne pourront même plus
communiquer à partir de 141 donc après
des interdictions d'écrire
voilà donc il y a la poste il y a le
recensement il y a l'habitat les
hôpitaux enfin est délégué à une
administration qui sert de qui sert de
Méry qui sert de qui sert de collecteurs
d'impôts il faut organiser tout ça et ça
s'appelle et ça s'appelle le Yoda raft
et donc il y a à Varsovie iodonrath donc
le chef qui s'appelle Adam tchernakov
qui est un chimiste un humaniste et qui
a été nommé par l'ancien maire de la
ville de Varsovie et Adams va réunir
autour de lui 24 personnes qui vont être
les décideurs l'interface réelle avec
les Allemands et puis il y aura une
armée entre guillemets de personnes de
1700 personnes qui vont jusqu'à 2000
personnes qui vont travailler pour
mettre en oeuvre les décisions du lieu
de rate
l'histoire de Adam chiracov peut-être
contesté est-ce qu'il a fait ça ou
est-ce qu'il a fait ça pour le bien des
Juifs c'est très très compliqué
Primo Levi dans un de ces ouvrages va
parler de zones grises c'est à dire que
c'est pour ça que je me permets de vous
poser
tant qu'on n'est pas dans cette
situation comment peut-on savoir comment
on se serait nous-même comporté comment
peut-on juger c'est quelque chose de
très très difficile donc c'est pas dans
si cette si c'était un homme c'est dans
un autre dans un autre livre et donc
chaniakov va exercer ses fonctions
jusqu'au 22 juillet
c'est la date de ce qu'on appelle
l'action rennaert c'est-à-dire la date
qui va qui va extermination voilà donc
en France on connaît tous la rafle du
Vél' d'Hiv la rade du Vél' d'hiver c'est
le 16 juillet
l'action Reinhardt à Varsovie c'est le
22 juillet de la même année on voit bien
qu'il y a un plan organisé pour voilà
pourquoi cette date de juillet pourquoi
cette année 42 alors en fait
l'histoire remonte en fait à
1941 au moment où
les nazis
rompent le pacte germanosoviétique et
envahissent par l'opération Barbarossa
en juin 41 envahissent les pays de l'Est
donc il respecte plus rien ils arrivent
et là
en s'appuyant plus ou moins sur des
éléments antisémites de la population
des
Ukrainiens des laitons etc ils vont
procéder à ce que le père du bois a
appelé la Shoah par balle et donc il y a
quatre groupes qui s'appelle Enza
scroopen les groupes d'action qui
accompagnent l'armée la Wehrmacht et qui
sont chargés ces quatre groupes
d'exterminés de regrouper et
d'extrêmement et d'exterminer et d'après
les certains historiens on raconte que
Himmler va visiter
si j'ose dire un de ces champs de
massacres je ne sais pas si c'est
babillard si c'est rambouillard ou c'est
un autre peu importe
qui se trouve en Ukraine babillard c'est
la banlieue de Kiev remboula c'est la
banlieue de kerkhov donc on est dans
une zone que l'on connaît bien
actuellement et bien il me l'air
il s'aperçoit que les soldats qui
exécutent
ces pauvres personnes les femmes les
enfants avec leur fusils ils sont
malheureux ah oui c'est les soldats qui
sont malheureux c'est pas ceux qui sont
physiques et donc il meurent il a de la
compassion pour ses soldats alors il
faut trouver il faut trouver une autre
solution et là on commence donc au
milieu de l'année 41 à chercher une
autre solution et c'est d'abord à ce
moment-là dans les arrières courent
du Reich la solution finale et la
solution finale étape on décide de
l'appliquer à la fameuse conférence de
venez qui a lieu en janvier 1942
qu'est-ce qu'on décide dans cette
conférence c'est la construction
des chambres asgas et des camps
d'extermination donc il y a un certain
nombre il n'a pas il n'a pas des
milliers il faut pas
très très bien organisés ils sont tous
en Pologne les communistes ils sont ils
sont tous en Pologne soit la majorité
est en Pologne dans la partie du
gouvernement de Hans Frank c'est-à-dire
au centre et puis il y a Auschwitz qui
est qui qui est de l'autre côté qui est
qui donc dans le grand RH à ce moment-là
des sites qui sont construits ce bboard
elle sait
et donc à ce moment là
peu à peu c'est un tout petit peu
c'est dire que donc ce ghetto on voit
bien au groupe tous les juifs et puis
peu à peu la solution finale s'impose et
donc le ghetto va se vider voilà
on passe de 300000 à 60 000 60000 on
passe pas 300000 parce qu'entreprise
il y a d'autres entre temps on a
regroupé les petits villages et on a
fait venir dans le dans le ghetto des
populations qui sont très très pauvres
très encore plus mal notice si j'ose
dire que les Varsoviens puisque ils
n'ont pas d'habitat ils n'ont rien ils
n'ont pas de quoi manger et donc la
mortalité de chez ces personnes là et
cinq fois supérieur à celle des Juifs
qui est déjà 10 fois supérieur à celle
du polonais donc vous imaginez le reste
10% en gros de voilà donc
quand on arrive en avril 43 c'est ça
voilà donc quand on arrive en avril 43
il faut savoir que du 22 juillet 1942
au 21 septembre
300000 personnes sont passées dans les
fours de traits
des Allemands qui sont extrêmement
pointilleux ont même pointé ce que je
pourrais appeler le record entre
guillemets c'est à dire le jour où il y
a eu le plus de déportation qui est
monté jusqu'à plus de 13000 personnes
qui ont été exterminées en une seule
journée
voilà c'est cette comptabilité cette
méthodologie mortifère allemande qui est
absolument
extraordinaire extraordinairement
bureaucratique et dans lesquels les si
on se réfère à Eichmann qui disait mais
moi je suis pas responsable c'est la
machine qui fait ça et
de défense la grande défense moi je suis
qu'un rouage de cette de cette histoire
organisée pour le pour que personne ne
se sentent le responsable définitif
on aurait donc à ce 19 avril donc
je sais pas on peut se mettre dans à la
place des gens qui qui sont là qui
savent que
c'est fini quoi pour eux ils ont vu
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que l'espoir
même quand les gens étaient même quand
les gens étaient rassemblés à longe lag
place je lisais des témoignages
c'est une place qui fait 80 mètres sur
30 et sur lequel les Allemands dans
laquelle les Allemands assemblés
rassemblés les juifs ils arrêtaient et
ils arrivaient jusqu'à 10000 personnes
et les uns sur les autres ils
attendaient les les wagons plombés de de
qui venaient et qui faisait
l'aller-retour avec trèbres Vinca et
c'est comme ça c'est certain certaines
personnes qui étaient affectées parce
qu'il y avait il fallait faire de la
maintenance il fallait bon il fallait
gérer ça et certaines personnes se sont
perçus que c'était les mêmes wagons et
donc là la l'idée que les Juifs étaient
déportés pour aller travailler vers
l'Est qui était cette idée
c'était l'idée propagée par les
Allemands et donc les Juifs pensaient
que c'était vrai en tout cas une partie
et donc une partie d'entre eux pensaient
que c'était vrai et une partie d'entre
eux disait on ne peut pas se révolter
contre les Allemands parce qu'on va nous
fusiller alors qu'on a peut-être avec
cette déportation la chance de survivre
et donc la révolte en elle-même était
pas soutenue par les gens étaient pas
populaire du tout
juste bon au milieu des années de
l'année 42 quand on voit ses
déportations il y en a qui disent c'est
fini on nous met à mort il y a des gens
qui arrivent à s'échapper de tradinga
qui raconte ce qui s'est passé et donc à
ce moment-là il y a vraiment une prise
de conscience et les jeunes qui qui
disent voilà on va pas continuer à et
c'est le terme qui a été utilisé se
laisser conduire comme des boutons à
l'abattoir on va se battre pour notre
dignité sachant que ce combat était
perdu complètement perdu d'avance alors
il y a tout d'abord une réunification
des des forces idéologiques parce que
la gérer la jeunesse et divisée en
plusieurs tendances voilà donc il y a
communiste il y a les socialistes il y a
les sionistes et là il y a une
unification en fait il y a deux forces
qui vont on a des armes alors les armes
ont été demandées à la Résistance
polonaise il faut savoir que la
Résistance polonaise d'après aussi les
historiens étaient plutôt de droite et
que les révoltés du ghetto darkovie
était plutôt de gauche donc là aussi il
y a pas eu une collabor une
collaboration de tout premier plan il
fallait faire des kilomètres pour
trouver un revolver quelques fusils donc
il y a eu des armes peu mais il y en a
eu qui ont été passés par évidemment
les égouts par ah bon des moyens de
fortune et
surtout les
les jeunes ont fabriqué des cocktails
Molotov ils ont fabriqué
quand vous voyez quand vous avez vu
récemment les images des des résistes de
la Résistance en Ukraine vous avez vu
les femmes qui remplissaient des bidons
pour faire des cocktails Molotov contre
les chats russes et bien c'était un peu
c'est un peu dans cet esprit là que les
choses se sont passées c'était une
seuleidarité complète avec il y avait
dans dans cette jeunesse il y avait des
des ingénieurs il y avait des des
gens il y a des gens qui savaient faire
et donc qui qui ont organisé ça alors
combien était-il on estime qu'ils
étaient qu'il y avait deux groupes un
groupe plutôt gauche et un groupe plutôt
de droite qui n'ont pas été pas sur le
même commandement et ils étaient 700 et
300 donc à peu près un millier un
millier de volts de personnes qui se
révoltent et ils ont fait des bas des
jeunes voilà et ce que avant de vous
répondre avant de prendre votre question
il y avait les les femmes qui se
battaient et ça les Allemands ont trouvé
que c'était absolument invraisemblable
que des femmes juives se battent et donc
ils se sont battus
ils avaient aucune expérience de tir ou
de quoi que ce soit donc il y a eu des
morts il y a eu des blessés les chiffres
je ne les ai pas précisément parce que
ils diffèrent suivant certains
témoignages de quelques dizaines à
quelques centaines chez les Allemands
mais je n'ai pas le chiffre exact
faudrait c'est très il y a eu cette
révolte
popularité assez grande quand même alors
cette révolte elle a marqué le marquer
elle a marqué l'opinion publique
en particulier par un geste qui était
tout à fait
étonnant qui était
le geste d'un monsieur
qui était le représentant d'une
organisation juive auprès du
gouvernement polonais
et donc ce monsieur s'appelait schmual
zing el boom il était à Londres auprès
du gouvernement polonais et quand il y a
eu la révolte du ghetto de Varsovie
il a plaidé pour de l'aide et il a eu
des réponses aucune réponse et donc il
s'est suicidé et donc celui que les
militants du Bund c'est la gauche
socialiste appelée Arthur donc Arthur
s'est suicidé le 12 mai donc quelques
jours avant la liquidation définitive du
ghetto et le ghetto le 16 mai c'est fini
et après c'est un champ de ruines il y a
plus rien on retrouve plus rien plus
rien plus rien il y a plus il y a plus
personne et quelques personnes ont été
arrêtées et sorti des sorties des plans
qui sortit des bunkers etc pardon juste
une seconde parce qu'on voit Willy
Brandt c'était photo qui a fait le tour
du monde ça joue douillet devant le
Varsovie c'est une photo évidemment qui
demande le pardon de l'Allemagne au fond
c'est absolument à ce moment-là et et
Willy Browns genou ils devons un
monument qui est le monument à la gloire
justement des résistants du ghetto de
vincendie avec à leur tête un certain
Annie lévitch qui était un jeune un
jeune résistant d'un mouvement sioniste
qui est appelé la chomère assaillir qui
était ce monument
on le doit un certain attendre à pas
port qui était un sculpteur et qui était
sauf de mémoire je crois inaugurée en
1950 qui se trouve actuellement juste en
face d'un nouveau musée qui est consacré
à l'histoire des Juifs de Pologne qui
s'appelle Pauline donc il se trouve donc
à Varsovie merci beaucoup vous êtes
s’arrêter
des œufs merci à vous je rappelle bah
voilà il faut aller au café de la plage
à Maurepas à partir du 18 avril c'est ça
c'est ça pour cette exposition consacrée
au ghetto de Varsovie merci beaucoup
d'années bitter je vous en prie Patricia
Mons merci beaucoup
[Musique]